[Music]
my name's Dan too bad
welcome back to afraid of monsters
I'm not afraid of anyone come here for
us come on come at me bro quick see ya
we're gonna all right we have a other
debt really oh oh yeah oh yeah y-yeah oh
no I don't like that girl she's stalking
me everywhere following me everywhere
did she just jump in realize I don't
want her
dragons all right it's cold everything
you thought about the chili anything I'm
just got dogs he's mother-effing dragons
all right all right let's go dragon it's
cool I get it I get it
I need to go back to Oh God oh this
container there's supposed to be a
ladder
everyone's I bear thee stop missing the
ladder Peter hey there's a battery
that's it that's all all this for the
better
where's the ladder please tell me what
okay you just give me that give me that
battery just I'm wasting my batteries to
get a [ __ ] battery come on come on
come on wait I see a weapon there oh no
where's the ladder oh there it is ha ha
I knew that all right give me that
there's a gun here yes yes I have a chef
game all right [ __ ] [ __ ] better
recognize my breasts that's cool I don't
try
ah not my face I don't know stalker go
alright let's skip out of here are you
wasted the logical part of that to move
I hope I have a friggin shock I mean I
have a free and batteries well needed
batteries all right all right now bros
and girls boys and girls no your old
bros i need to yeah everyone's like our
girls bras - yes of course girls I'm
property but now we're going to make
something historical happen we're going
to [ __ ] a Rubens mom in the ass alright
where we get [ __ ] instead wait wait
wait
let's do this instead give me the deagle
what am i why the [ __ ] am i not isn't
that a [ __ ] why did i quicksave you at
all [ __ ] face alright alright alright
alright let's [ __ ]
now again let's [ __ ] Ruben's man my brow
it doesn't like my time what oh yes of
course
maybe the shotgun is better all right
let's try this
getting tired of you and your ah it
doesn't like ribbons mom hates me
fine I can't do this I did it before
sometime I think yeah no no no oh I got
one shot iron alright alright
she wants shots kill me it's not fair
it's not fair
I really have that little hell I
shouldn't have taken that damage earlier
I counted me that health [ __ ] dragons
probably dragons oh no we can't continue
here [ __ ] dragons [ __ ] up my [ __ ]
dragon eyes [ __ ] up my [ __ ]
Oh Oh cool cool cool now I will suck
allows I got two shots at the room is
not that's one shot
oh no she [ __ ] me oh no oh she died
she died all right I just need to with
the deagle hey Monty no no okay okay a
new tactic quick safe okay that's not
good
she [ __ ] eyeballs stop shooting
eyeballs
they should stop their brothers mom
brother Ramon still lay back god damn
this is an epic battle between the arrow
of Islam oh no she got me I know
oh no maybe if I crouch maybe okay
they're like maybe if I jump
no that's chops a French baguette leave
the charge I'm chopping energy charging
this full speed top speed
boom one more shot that she is my ass
and going to rape the waiter your
bathroom is mom yeah
ah that's a good ribbons mom oh yes
Reubens mom I can't tell you how good
that felt oh man
Oh Dragons all right side Jason's penis
everywhere that's going here
rubezh hahahaha he mad brah I killed him
Imran
ah okay they are met get that much why
did I it's cool I have something no
that's not
not as much room as much
I forget shouldn't have wasted so much
on my what is this oh oh no I couldn't
you just shot that why didn't I just too
bad
can I wait let's do this I need that
ammo are safe here no I don't want to
say I saved like a [ __ ]
all right no no we save save girls why
and that's loud is this one
I won't take any chances God dang it
we got the top top top top top top top
yay battery the top top top top top all
right let's go here hello in Lane hair
and one wanna stop
I don't like this
go up
I don't like it
take a look I mean
you tell me what got them added Charles
Charles I know you're handicapped and I
feel really bad for you but I'm sorry
just break the [ __ ] hell out of me
oh no that's a waste of ammo all right
Charles where do you want it tell me why
do you want me to finish you in the
penis I can't decide what subscribe I'm
sorry Charles
I'm terribly sorry about this it was not
my decision if it helps all right we got
some ammo and intellivision I'm taking
this I'm late not a quick same
tap top anyone want to speak some things
with me all right fine let's beat it
sounds [ __ ] Ruben I told you
laughs how about that
I killed your mom my dad how about dad
how are ya
I filled up your address I feel like no
well done sir you have killed me I'm
just gonna hang out here for a couple
more seconds is that a hand coming out
of your mouth I never know this I
thought you weren't an octopus I'm so
sorry
all right then you want to speak you
wanna dance I wanna dance
you wanna dance with me the one in the
else stick out no he spoke Japanese
right in my face good day all right I'm
gonna try
I wanna speak Chinese with me one speak
I speak fluent Japanese kill him before
I make any more [ __ ] jokes ah no that
was a lunch at well done Reuben your
mama would be proud
I'm so sorry she's done down
I just want to put this big girl in here
mouth [ __ ] screwed I got your corn in
our Reuben ha ha I'm so sorry about your
mom not really
alright cuz I can factor all right we
got health thank [ __ ] god let's keep
on hold all right I was gonna say was
someone was actually offended that I
call these companies like oh no oh [ __ ]
I'm sorry about your face bro oh please
don't come at me I have the ego okay bye
don't play [ __ ] zombies never playback
not fair but Dee going in their mouth
but but they're you're on you want to
speak to please BAM that's my main
language [ __ ]
even though I just shot you and they
guess it doesn't really make sense all
right
I just giving me out let's do it quick
say hello class anyone in here come at
me bro
come at me BAM you're dead bro
why did I feel how does it be able to be
dead huh personal only no one's watching
I don't like this I don't like this at
all
bookshelf can have it be trusted
my breath come on brah
huh finger top huh
no you're not [ __ ] alright let's big
Japanese fun [ __ ] quick same here at
me add quick load all right back
damn it I need that I can't afford
losing anymore dad
how's that [ __ ] how's it feel to be a
pledge attached how does it feel to be
[ __ ] bar tell me tell me how are your
dad you can't pound it maybe a Ruben
what's going on generate it sweet
let's press that all right I sure what
the [ __ ] it then huh
huh God dang it
alright fine we got to generate the
running absolutely no [ __ ] battery
all right I could have a little Beth way
all right so I guess it generators down
here and stop so let's ask out good
thing I have so much battery come out of
my bra
oh you speak Japanese cool yeah Davis
guys you just had to
oh no no matter the way through seconds
God dang it all right we need to go up
here yet
no all right fine fine cycle cycle day
long
all right shotgun boom gotta get that oh
oh oh all right then
all right let's do it quick save here
you get this feelings gotta meet more
dragons get outta here oh all right
Hydra ah two girls
this is worse than two girls on cap am I
supposed to do freaking fangirls are
stocking ah
alright sorry girls all right I just
want to go here or here Christ but there
they want from me no no yes I made it
ribbon yeah
damn you Ruben now I have to kill you
then oh no I don't want to become days
right now [ __ ] away some deagle shot on
Ruben [ __ ]
hope you're happy with it hope you're
[ __ ] happy about yourself and every
angry I just [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you're wasting all my house I hope
you're happy
up sincerely you're [ __ ] happy
all right fine let's press another
[ __ ] butter that's what this game is
all about which door this one No
this one no of course not all right I'm
just gonna go here I'm just gonna nope
of course that that ladies Wow they
dumbed one they are raping me right now
there are those that are amazingly I
don't like that very much
alright alright alright we're back in
ribbon fine fine fine fine
alright go anyway
freaking you can't go alright
Reuben [ __ ] you I just want to click
this bottom all right close to me I
think I clicked it at least
this dodge these [ __ ]
all right I'm on a car [ __ ] work
works every time
I think you can go here now oh [ __ ]
that's not good for anyone all right
I'm sorry you're killing out maybe once
or anything did I ever boo come on let's
go oh why did you tell me all right I
recorded 15 minutes jaysis guys why did
you tell me hope you bros enjoy like him
favors if you did subscribe to form a
rotary I'll see
[Music]
[Music]
oh my goodness Oh get out of my face
before I order - yeah I don't want to